[Musique]
arrangeront les enfants des écoles
primaires sont des enfants de rue du
question de cantine ils vont déjeuner
comme des grands au restaurant d'enfants
un menu scientifiquement équilibré tient
compte en ce qui concerne le choix des
poissons de la dernière circulaire du
ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
vient d'interdire dans toutes les
cantines scolaires toute boisson
alcoolisée pour les moins de 14 ans
cette mesure salutaire et détendu à la
campagne où l'instituteur est tenu de
surveiller le choix de la boisson qui
accompagne le casse-croûte quotidien la
sobriété est une bonne habitude elle est
la base même de la santé de nos enfants
[Musique]